Across Europe, there are lots of strange
tourist attractions that started out
as useful public transport infrastructure.
Venice has its gondolas.
Lots of cities have cable cars
and funicular railways.
And Funchal, here, the capital of Madeira,
has the basket carts.
They are wooden toboggans
on smooth runners
that are powered by people in straw hats
pushing them.
And, uh, there aren't any seatbelts.
- From the start,
they used the sledges to bring some wood
from the mountains to the town by the sea.
After that, they adapt for tourists.
In total, we are 154 men.
We have about 60 baskets running
most of the day.
The toboggan is made of wood, normal wood.
And if it sticks to the floor,
we put some grease under the basket
and it slides much better.
We have a workshop where
we fix the baskets, and we build new ones.
And we keep rotating the baskets.
(IN PORTUGUESE:)